in other world news for him any results
from Afghanistan's presidential election
show incumbent Ashraf Ghani has secured
a slim majority the result had been
expected in October but was only
released by the Independent Election
Commission on Sunday Ghani secured just
over 50% of the vote the office of his
main rival Abdullah Abdullah say they
don't accept the results the Electoral
Commission says the final count could
change or hermanus that speak to Habib
Warnock who's a political analysts and
founding member of transparency
Afghanistan he joins us live from Kabul
thank you for your time Ashraf Ghani is
opponent Abdullah Abdullah already
challenging the result of this
preliminary count do you expect the
results to change after the final count
well I don't I don't expect the results
to change much but I expect a lot of
volatility in terms of agreement of the
final decision chief executive Abdullah
has already challenged the the
preliminaries are saying that you still
have a lot of fraudulent votes that
needs to be sorted out which could bring
President Ghani is 50 point 64 percent
votes down the the case now goes to the
and to the elections complains
Commission which will looks at which
will look at the complaints but at the
same time I think we are looking at some
sort of agreement between Abdullah and
president Ghani I think we we are sort
of going back to what happened in 2014
you have had elections which which had
very little turnout from the Afghan
general public and then you had massive
amount of corruptions there was the
issue of electoral biometric votes
people got to vote who would not
biometric the devices of biometrics were
flawed and Abdullah Abdullah is raising
these issues now that you have to sort
of remove the fraudulent votes from from
the overall votes which might bring down
president ghani's votes but overall I
think the Electoral Commission will also
stick to 50 point 64 percent might have
a lot of grievances from Abdullah
Abdullah and other candidates and I
don't know where this all leads to right
gong
had called on Afghan voters to turn out
in large numbers and give a mandate to
the new leadership to negotiate peace
with the Taliban but as we saw the
turnout was very low the lowest turnout
in fact of any Afghan election this will
not deliver a strong mandate for the
winner will it and and where will it
leave this these peace talks with the
Taliban
so elections is one issue and then the
peace process another issue I think the
results of this election will have
tremendous impact on the peace process
from what we know the Taliban and the
United States of America are very close
from signing the peace deal president
Ghani has been saying this over and over
again from the past four years that he
has plan he has strategy for a
sustainable Afghan peace process but on
the other side we look at it that he has
yet to appoint his negotiate
negotiations team there's a lot of
disagreement among president ghani's
team you have a vice president Amrullah
Saleh who has a very hawkish view about
Taliban and about this war so the
Afghans will be will sit back and try to
make sense out of this whole situation
that Ronnie's term 2.0 how well it will
help the Afghans for reaching a
sustainable peace agreement with the
Taliban it's still a little bit early
but Ronnie's team is mix of hawkish and
dovish and sometimes these hawkish views
when and and Ronnie's team so I don't
know whether we are going whether this
wall will sort of continue or we might
put an end to it because for most of the
Afghans it's not about elections it's
about stopping this madness it's about
stopping this bloodshed that needs to be
stopped at whatever cost Howie wore doc
thank you so much for talking to us
there from Kabul